so okay so this was great great
discourse here going back and forth
appreciate everybody's commentary on
this let's go to the next topic look we
know what happened yesterday it's all
over the news facebook facebook whatsapp
whatsapp uh uh uh instagram everybody's
texting this your facebook you text me
first guys is my facebook
is it just me because you're thinking
maybe it's me it's like it's the world
that was taken down
real quick
you noticed that i was at a conference
at the forum yesterday and all at first
they're blocking me man it's all i knew
it they're on to me
and then uh it was the world
bro be fair you didn't believe i was
actually shadow band on instagram and
then you saw it what did you see tell
the world they don't like you they don't
like care they don't want you to be
heard
and maybe for good reason gerard
all right so let's let's talk about this
article from cnn okay facebook instagram
what's up goes down facebook's week just
went from bad to worse facebook content
whatsapp all suffered outage midday
monday we're aware that some people are
having trouble uh accessing our apps and
products facebook said on twitter the
outage came the morning after 60 minutes
aired a segment and in facebook
whistleblower francis
hagin claimed the company is aware of
its platforms are used to spread hate
violence and
misinformation and that facebook has
tried to hide that evidence
shares of facebook were down more than
five percent in mid-day trading monday
putting it on pace for its worst trading
day
in nearly a year now here's what's crazy
about it while this is going on
yesterday you're at that event i'm
interviewing a guy named sean spiegel
who's a whistleblower who used to work
at facebook as a moderator okay
so he went from a moderator of choosing
the regular things that's coming up you
know memes all this stuff then he gets
promoted to the next level where he
really saw the kind of videos that was
being put up by the way
i've never had a
warning at the beginning of an interview
where i personally come up and i say
don't watch this interview okay i'm
telling people do not
watch it because how uncomfortable and
disturbing this video is now
if you want to be aware watch the
interview but i'm telling you in advance
so we put a warning sign we put all that
stuff in this interview
have we ever done this before in any
interview we've never done this with was
this a pre-planned interview it just had
a creation
you called me i was talking to him no
meaning like did you set this up weeks
in advance or did you say no no no no
this was set up facebook goes down get
him on the line it just so happened that
it was happening it was a coincidence
okay that's what i'm saying it was
pre-planned this interview is supposed
to go on in two three weeks it's not
scheduled to go out this week david yes
or no yeah correct this wasn't this was
just a complete coincidence this is
complete so yesterday i'm saying so
gerard comes out of nowhere and he says
he just got back from new york says pat
do you mind if i sit in okay do you mind
if i sit in there listen to this okay
adam the stuff i heard my stuff like
it's this
he said the environment at this place as
a moderator his job is to look at
everything that's coming there's about a
thousand people that work this is a
company that was contracted out with
facebook that eventually they said we're
not going to work for you anymore a
company that does 16 billion per year
cognizant technology solutions it's a 16
billion a year company it's not a small
company anyways he says in our facility
there was a thousand of us working there
it was two bathrooms that they had there
there was
what did he say was always on the wall
he says you know people would poop and
pee in the uh in the woody color in the
sink
they were so meant no no they were so
mentally broken they were so mentally
broken that
uh after weeks on the job people would
like start smearing feces on the wall
and like it's pretty nasty yeah and by
the way that's not let's just say that's
a two that's a two the stories he says
ghost david would you agree i'm not even
going to tell you the stories because
it's so uncomfortable yeah it's very
graphic very very as as graphic as you
can possibly what's the reasoning behind
this so these guys aren't enslaved they
can choose to work here right now no no
it's very very odd very very odd
explain it
well it's extremely uncomfortable he
says he says at any point somebody's
sitting there your job is to watch the
video and then send a report to facebook
this video needs to be taken down and
facebook comes back and says no that
facebook that video is going to stay up
because this is a private group and it's
not a public group and it's only a
private group so therefore we're going
to leave this up yeah and he says
facebook's position was the more videos
like this we keep up the fbi and cops
are going to be able to find a bad guy
to go get him and the guy's like that's
not what's happening and then i said let
me go a little bit deeper with this by
the way says people are doing this
watching videos all of a sudden they're
throwing up he says at any point people
were throwing up at their workplace he
says it smelled it was horrible it was
horrific terrible situation at this
workplace what they're doing because
somebody has to watch his videos so
anyways this happens we interview him
then facebook is down then we go live
with it yesterday i've never had this
many people message me about an
interview i did pat i'm having a hard
time watching this this is crazy and the
guy
is would you say he's part of the lgbt
he said he said he said he's um he made
a comment yeah he he is
he's not by any stretch of the
imagination this is not a maga guy this
is not anybody that's far right this
this is a guy who who
is an animal rights activist and
sympathetic to the lgbt movement and
that those were his words um
and
you know he cried in the interview when
you start talking about animals and what
they were doing
apparently there's an entire look this
is snuff this is nothing more this is a
snuff this is snuff
and there's there's groups where people
go and they and they pay and they use
the facebook marketplace to pay for this
video i mean he described um
he described bestiality he described um
forced incest he described um you know
animal cruelty while bestiality was
occurring i mean like really as
by the way when he said like hell like
like what you would imagine would be in
him gerard i did not know what bistiano
lee meant bestiality meant i i put on
google while he's talking bestiality
yeah and i'm like
close immediately yeah the stuff that
he's talking about no i'm not good um
and this is the reason why people
watching the videos are puking throwing
up going no bro if you hear the video
like there's one situation with a pig
yeah
that's put it like this yeah it's when i
walked in the office yeah and i saw pat
and gerard and they were explaining this
stuff
they were shook
i mean it was like it was it was very it
was very like this the vibe was there's
no reason to assume the guy's lying we
haven't verified it like we're still in
the process of verifying his claims
we're trying to get you know two or
three other people to verify it as well
to make sure that that what he's saying
is is not you know exaggerated in any
way so look take it anecdotally at this
point right this is one guy put one of
the clips put one of the clips you know
which one i'm talking about so i asked
him a question i say so do you can you
check anybody's uh uh
that's a whole separate
beyond
like this was insane this was crazy okay
just watch this go ahead and press play
go ahead and press play
is that the one
i say do you guys check instant
messenger so you guys were able to see
what's being said in the instant
messenger and text messages or no yes
also whatever we post there and we're
communicating you see all of it yes
absolutely
[Laughter]
everything that's communicated here if
you wanted to see all of it you can
easily see it yes and yes you have
access to who like
do is there levels of clearance on who
you have access to want to be able to go
see let me see if this one guy i don't
like let me see what he stands for i'm
going to go see what this guy's saying
to this person here could you do that or
was there limitations to what they sent
to you
no uh in the general queue there were
limitations where i was they were not
were you ever tempted to see something
we're higher ups go back a little bit go
back a little bit
go back a little bit okay go ahead go
ahead were you ever tempted to see some
conversations of people that were higher
ups or no
i was tempted yes but not specifically
higher ups uh i have to be honest
politics isn't my thing i was more
curious about seeing what my cousin was
saying up in georgia
so he's working there and he wants to go
see what his cousin says but he has
access to everybody but what he said was
politics weren't his thing yeah but the
place was the most politically he talked
about that he talked about that yeah
yeah and politics people were there
specifically because of their politics
and that to me was the most shocking
part i mean the the what he was saying
about the bestiality was was gross but
anybody that's ever had live league seen
the internet
you know that this stuff's out there and
it's heinous
this
the fact that anybody can have access to
anybody's whatsapp anybody's instant
messenger not stuff that was reported
dude not something that somebody
manually reports he could go search adam
sosnick's dms
pull it up and read them
see them you don't want no part of that
dude
i want some of them dms dude
it's
this is this is privacy okay there's a
part of it when he says i just care what
my cousin in georgia said it's funny
obviously meaning he could spy on his
cousin in georgia
i didn't think that's so funny
but if humorously but if he wants to see
what
two senators are talking to each other
and there you know if he wants to see
what anybody in power to go back and
look at all their history you know
everything he can find that out and
that's facebook so this is not facebook
this is a third party facebook's given
access to that that's really crazy so
think about it third party third party
yeah is what's the general queue so
here's the question i asked because
because when i was with rogan it was
hillary clinton's servers if you
remember when i was with rogan rogan we
we talked about jack dorsey and he said
uh i like jack he says i like what he's
doing jack went on two times the first
time that people said you didn't push
him too hard he came back and he pushed
him a little bit harder with some of the
questions with his general counsel there
though
i get that but the part is when he said
you know jack wants twitter to be more
open he would like it to be two
different formats with twitter one is
like on the back end where you can say
free for all do whatever you want to say
i wanted two twitters he wanted two
twitters yeah so so for me
i go and i ask the one question i said
okay facebook like yesterday we haven't
even gone to what we think happened
yesterday that's really what we got to
get into because i got thoughts yeah so
i said so
let's let's give the guy the benefit of
the doubt they got 60 000 plus employees
okay that doesn't count contractors so i
had another 100 000 contractors people
that are working offsite but they're not
w2 they're 10.99 contracts that they're
working whatever their number is let's
just say 60 000 employees
maybe he doesn't know what's going on
maybe maybe he doesn't know what's going
on but listen you got like i got stuff
going on here we got 40 employees but
you guys go out i don't even know where
you guys went i don't know what's going
on so imagine with 40 i don't know
what's going on you think you're gonna
know what sixty thousand we got sixteen
thousand seventeen thousand insurance
agents yeah in 150 uh offices nationwide
do you think i know everything that's
going on now
so go to sixty thousand employees
because
could this be a part where
when you're a ceo at this level he's
probably got 30 c-suite executives he's
got 20 c-suite executives
who are the people that knew
did they report up that the people at
the top know why is this content being
left up this is a compliance issue so
this leads to
yesterday facebook going down so why did
facebook go down let's let's talk about
possibilities i'll throw some out there
and then you give yours go ahead you
have a thought yeah yeah before we get
into that more importantly you also
asked him about how does shadow banning
work and do they do they act you said
i've been doing this for a long time he
admitted he admitted to social
engineering there's videos pat said i've
been doing this for a long time and the
videos they'll rise they'll rise they'll
rise then they'll peter off but there's
some videos they rise they rise their
eyes and then they fall off a cliff is
that organic or he goes absolutely not
that's somebody saying that they don't
want this message out there and they
just turn it off they just turn it off
they said somebody's saying like one
person making that decision i said the
same thing who has that kind of
authority who has that power
not at his level he reports and gives
facebook what to do facebook chooses
what they want to do with and they can't
delete anything yeah they simply watch
and sent in
that's what his job is and then facebook
has to decide so on a couple of the
instances facebook left the stuff up and
he kept going back he kept going back he
kept going back he kept going back they
said no this is going to stay up we're
not taking this down
so yeah but facebook has to be aware
like the whistleblower story i know
we're going to get into but facebook has
to be aware that
sean spiegel whatever his name is or
billy mcgillicuddy or john doe is going
to be able to speak out about this
like this guy has no loyalty to facebook
at any point he can do an interview with
you he gets fired doesn't like his job
people are throwing up around me [ __ ]
quits now like how many there's a
thousand people working in a room and
this is what they're doing you're right
how many of them can speak out you're
right
has to know that they're so arrogant i
think i think that they know that they
can control the narrative to such a
level right that they they know right
they know like look even in our minds
there's a little bit in all of us right
now they're saying man
we're really we're talking about this
stuff we're really going there we're
talking each one of us if we're being
honest we're saying look we're doing it
we're going for it man we hope to we
hope the listeners appreciate this
because we're we're all putting
ourselves out there what what is that
what is that inside of all of us because
all of us know that these guys are all
holding it over us and all the time when
that guy said it pat asked that question
yesterday and i was sitting in the back
i said holy [ __ ] this guy just admitted
to social engineering that's not
moderation
that's manipulation the way he said it
he says i said do you have a problem
what they're doing on the left and the
right he says well on the right there
were people on the right that were
saying what were the stuff that they
were saying i asked some questions you
think trump should be off of facebook
you think he should be off he says well
let me think about this one here because
on one end
if he was a regular person doing what he
was doing
probably yes if he was a regular person
but if he's the president
and he's doing what he's doing in the
january 6th event yes he kind of went up
there and he's the one that started it
but later on that night at six o'clock
he did come and tell people go home and
i like he this guy's like he's going
through the sequence on how he's
explaining it right
and then he says no i think he should
still be on and then he says i said what
were the people pushing on the right so
he's what did he say on the right left
no no the right the right was pushing uh
just being nasty bullying libtards
that's right so and then he said on the
left
there's too much push on kids uh being
part of the lgbt lgbtq community which
which i support he says which i support
he supports the lgbt community he says
it's too big of a push amongst kids and
he says it's too much too big of a push
on transgender uh uh have an influence
over kids and that's being left out
there and this segregation yeah i said
the left is they they don't want to
coexist there's too many people that
just they want they think there should
be two worlds by the way if you watch
this interview you'll say this guy's on
the left you won't see this guy's on the
right like if you watch this guy you're
not going to say oh you know he's a
supporter of you know center really
right i mean no i don't think he's
center i'm going to put this guy center
left because
there were still some error but but for
the most part he's trying to stay as
reasonable as possible yeah he was
trying to be as reasonable possible
very level-headed the craziest part of
the interview for people that haven't
seen it is how matter-of-factly he
answered these insane questions like
he's you know are we are we watching
like you know it was like a gotcha
question like are you guys listening to
our our uh messages yeah absolutely
yeah yeah yeah can you search messages
from yeah no problem
so wait is is facebook turning off uh
you know viral content yeah yeah they
determine what messages they want out
like he was just so matter-of-fact it
was like it was like bone chilling how
matter of fact this guy was about the
social engineering in your opinion what
level of credibility does this guy have
one through ten in your opinion
i'm going to give this guy seven seven
eight
okay yeah hey let me do let me tell you
yeah because he doesn't have a bone to
pick with facebook he has a bone to pick
he he's a he's an animal activist he's
his main goal was just to
animal yeah no it's like it's it's all
about animal he saw uh one time they he
saw a video about oh so so i'm i said
what was the most disturbing video he
said
one time there was a video these two
boys no these two boys were taking the
iguanas from the tail and they were
smashing the iguanas on the ground so
hard and iguanas were having the scream
i've never heard any i never knew
iguanas could scream like that and
they're hitting the head yeah and they
did this with different types of animals
and they would put it in their private
facebook group and that stayed on
silence and the lamb stuff she says like
iguana like it was so like
who who says so you have to know how
he's wired he's saying let me ask you
without okay this is just a hypothetical
sick stuff that's going on yeah right
sick stuff without facebook without
social media
these [ __ ] sickos would be doing this
regardless
now they're doing it for the world to
see or for people to see
and
maybe
maybe they could be held accountable for
their
heinous acts
is that maybe a good thing that you
could hold these people accountable
because there's people i've talked about
i mean i know a buddy of mine he's fine
now i mean ironically he's a big mega
guy but this guy would put his cat in
the microwave as a kid about five
seconds i'm like what the [ __ ] are you
doing you [ __ ] weirdo yeah okay
um and then i was like dude this is what
are you doing like this isn't cool like
we're all you know we're we're 12 years
old like this isn't funny yeah ha ha
like not cool yeah okay but this is
pre-social media stuff this is minor
whatever but there's people that do this
sick stuff yeah no and as much as we're
railing against social media right now
maybe it's you know it's kind of like
shooting yourself in the future
their job isn't to they're sending this
to facebook they're not sending the [ __ ]
to the authorities
but if the authorities can see this kind
of stuff
again you guys got to watch the video he
brought up that claim and he was like we
need to bring this to the authorities
and then according to him he was like
facebook was like we don't need that
type of publicity we don't need that you
know like
if the authority so facebook doesn't
want to be cop because if they become
cop oh yeah the the category of the type
of business they become changes and you
as the user lose trust in community like
even right now we talked about the fact
that the guy says they can read every
message what percentage of the people
that are listening are kind of like oh
so i'm going to make sure i filter out
those three things i would say some
people probably want to play that's what
i'm saying so i think people are just
gonna carry on with their lives but no
no no but 10 is 10 10 is not a small
number so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]